Hello Freak bitches,
I was lucky enough to fight there in 2004,
2005 and we were pulling
40,000 people every show.
We had a live 40,000 people and that
you'd walk out to the arena and then you
check out the stage and sometimes you
come up through the floor for your walkout
or a kid.
It was just unbelievable.
They had like some elevator that would
make you rise up through the floor.
I remember in the back room once I was
trying to find the stairs and I've asked
the lady,
Whoa,
where do I go?
And she goes,
oh,
stand on that thing.
It's like,
no way.
And she goes,
Oh yes.
It's like,
fuck yes.
Um,
I remember coming up through the floor
and then all of a sudden they're all,
there's 40,000 people
right in front of you.
And it's like,
wow,
he's amazing.
And then we had a TV audience of
20 million people in Tokyo also.
So it would be a delayed
broadcast by about an hour.
So by the time we finished our fight
and then on the bus with a TV on the bus
and watch pretty much what you'll find
your way back on the way to the hotel.
But Thailand was pretty cool to Thailand,
wouldn't have crowds.
I'm song troy who was fighting for,
he'd have,
he'd make all these money
from the TV production,
so he did live shows in the middle of
nowhere and people will drive for hours to
be present to,
for a live event.
And we'd have 40,000,
60,000.
Um,
there's this one big event once a year
called the king's birthday and we get
100,000 people plus every
year on the fifth of December.
I was lucky to fight on
then four years in a row.
So the first time I went on the ring,
it was the first time that I owe my
knees went weak because as far as I could
see was the ocean heads.
And I started trembling.
And then I've come out in the first round.
I've tried this,
I've tried to finish him.
And then by the fifth round I sort of
spent my pennies and fell over a couple of
times and then I'm losing them points.
And then the next year I
got invited back and I said,
oh no,
I'm not going to get spooked at this time,
this time.
Like,
like the UFC Gds,
like you're talking about all the time.
I had the GDS,
the first one,
the second time it's like,
no,
I'm not gonna I'm going to this time,
I'm going to love it and
I'm going to absorb it.
I'm going to run with it.
So I've got out there,
big breath in 100,000 people.
And then,
um,
I had the greatest fight of my life.
That was 10 western is verse 10 toys.
And I was the only western
of I get getting high fire
from ties back the change
room.
And then the last time I did it,
um,
there was probably only
25,000 people a little tiny.
And I was looking at the background.
Ah,
Geez.
What's going on?
Where is everyone?
This is,
this is,
this is sad.
It was nuts.
But you can tell the
difference between $95,000,
$100,000.
Uh,
there was,
there was a little spot near the hot
dog stand where you could have another
5,000 people.
Easy.
Absolutely.
I was in an elevator one time with a guy
and he recognized me as a comedian and
he wanted to do one of my bits to me,
but he got it wrong and the bit was just
a little bit I used to do about saying
you too,
at the wrong time,
getting out of a cab at the airport and
the driver goes to have a nice flight.
You Go Yuto.
So,
so that's the bit.
So I'm in the elevator with him,
this guy.
And he goes,
Oh,
you're a comedian,
right?
And said,
yeah,
yeah.
How you doing?
You know,
when he goes,
you're the guide,
it says and you all the time.
So I'm not going to call them out on it.
I'm honored.
Even knows who I am so I'm not
going to embarrass somebody.
Said,
yeah,
that's me,
that's me.
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
I do that all the time.
I'm always saying,
and you at the wrong time,
and now I'm like,
no,
I shouldn't,
I should have corrected the guy.
You know what I mean?
And he goes,
yeah,
there's probably not a day
goes by that I don't yell and,
and you and I'm thinking this
is getting off the tracks.
So the elevator door opens,
it's in a casino with a bunch of
people and we walk off the elevator,
I'm going one way and
he goes the other way.
So he starts yelling to me thinking it's
gonna be funny what he thinks is my bit
in a casino now with hundreds of
people and he's going and you know,
and you know,
and I'm thinking I'm the only guy here
who knows what this guy's talking about
and I don't know what he's talking about.
He
was very,
very straight.
You can run into people man,
and you just use the egg
when you should've zagged.
And you run into someone who's completely
out of their fucking mind and then
they become a part of your life.
I mean,
that can happen.
You could definitely run
into the wrong people,
especially if it's a girl,
especially if you're single.
He just,
for whatever reason,
start talking to someone and it turns
out they're fucking crazy and then you,
you know,
that's a problem with men.
Men are willing to.
We're willing to look past a
lot of shit of a chick's hot.
Like I know a lot of guys that have
gotten involved with girls that are just
completely out of their fucking mind,
but they're pretty and they're just like,
oh,
hey,
she's a little weird,
but no,
no.
She was a guy who would
be running from her.
Imagine if that was a gal and she beat.
She had giant tits and I'd
be running back to answer.
Exactly.
Yeah,
that's me.
I'm that guy.
Hey
Man,
let's do it up.
Take it to a restaurant.
She's yelling out and you and you.
And then when she sees your act and then,
uh,
like she sees an old recording
and she sees that bitch.
Fuck you.
She didn't even tell me you
wouldn't make it an asshole.
Fucking selfish.
Bz Brian,
are you doing it like
during the wedding vows?
And she says,
and you and you go,
all right,
I got to tell you that,
you know,
when he hosted the espys in 2001,
Oj Simpson was just forced to give his
heisman trophy back to Fred Goldman
because Oj lost the civil suit,
so he had to give money
reparations back there.
Fred Goldman and Nicole.
So he didn't have any money,
so we should take my heisman
trophy for whatever that's worth.
So Fred Goldberg takes
it and now he owns it.
So the next week or the me enormous
hosts espys Charles Woodson,
the guy who won the heisman trophy,
the first defensive guy ever
sitting in the front row.
First joke,
norm tells.
He looks in the front row and he says,
Hey,
Charles Woodson,
and you won the heisman trophy.
No one can ever take that away
from your first defensive guy,
win the heisman trophy.
No one can ever take that away from him.
And everybody applauds.
It's like a real nice thing and
it settles down and one goes,
no one can ever take
that heisman trophy away.
And then he pauses and said,
unless of course you kill
your wife and a waiter
at bomb hit it really well.
It was a.
yeah,
it was a radio studio
and it was Ken Griffey.
Jr was,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
what did they expect as normal?
Fucking Mcdonald.
Maybe not task,
but actually it makes
me love him even more.
Norm and I talked.
We sat next to each other
randomly on an airplane,
talked the whole way back,
just shot the shit,
talking about all kinds of stuff.
I was like,
yeah,
I quit smoking while ago.
Just done with it and for
whatever reason the plane lands.
And he goes,
man,
I just want a cigarette.
And he just walks in this door that
you hadn't smoked in like x amount of
months.
But just decided to talking
about it on the airplane,
how he quit smoking,
that he just wanted another cigarette.
He went outside and he's just smoking.
I go,
what happened?
I thought you quit smoking.
He goes,
I did until just now.
I just wanted a cigarette.
The movie,
me and him,
I did a buddy comedy with
him and it got bad reviews,
so the reviewer in my hometown paper said,
Artie Lange has all the charm of a date,
rapists,
fruit,
true line.
So norm looks at it and he
calls me up and he goes,
hey man,
that's fucking great.
A date.
Rapists has to have way more
charm than a regular rapish.
Oh God bless.
That made me feel better.